[Music]
thought of backlash this shirt sparked a
lot of backlash from both fans and Coco
McAvoy sounds like a [ __ ] that sounds
like a developmental wrestler right
Coco McAvoy is an NXT wrestler
peace
I hear the shirt but we spoke with the
with the founder of black lives matter
LA and she says the shirt is harmful
why is it harmful
is he about to tell you with a sassy
attitude I'm assuming in big hoop
earrings yeah it's as harmful as
stealing millions of dollars from
[ __ ] your the people you claim to
support buying gigantic Mansions it's a
massive giant mansions and very
exclusive neighborhoods a
ustroversy for Kanye West
photo
Paris fashion show yay and conservative
that's I just she's right I don't think
you know I don't think Kanye West has
cut out to really deal with the pressure
of all this controversy I mean I don't
know I mean because you know he's never
had to deal with being reviled and
controversial before I hope he can hold
up to the mental pressure you know Marsh
I'm going to say something it's almost
like he does it on purpose it's almost
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah he's
playing you people like you guys are
morons
commentator Candice Owens wore shirts
with they bang got it you know what I
was about to ask right they banged right
so listen the only question I have here
is how many times
did Candace Owens bang Kanye West and
I'm allowed to say that because it could
it could be zero all of the times there
is no way in the world these two
didn't [ __ ]
look at that look at the picture on the
right oh yeah yeah looks like their
hands in each other's Pockets yes sorry
sorry sorry guys but
the phrase White lives matter on the
back from Kim to Candace can you imagine
why I took a point
phrase activists say is harmful and has
been used bro could you imagine the salt
if Kanye West
Owens get married and then file for
custody of Kardashian's kids
oh my God that would be civil war you
know what I hate Candace Owens but I
might turn around on Candace Owens if
she's causing this much [ __ ] let's
[ __ ] doing that in that I'm in yeah
white supremacist groups it acts it
absolutely feels
better yeah that's why you're using a
webcam mic in your little [ __ ] in
your little middle class home and he has
like 52 Mansions hey stupid [ __ ] you
understand Kanye's life has been like 45
years of cheap stunts that's what he
does he's cheap stunt guy he's the PT
Barnum of rap yes no he's always got a
gimmick he's the Paul Heyman of raps
he is human circus hey somebody put a
top hat on him but put him in the center
in the center stage
he's the Super Dave Osborne of rap there
you go
Kanye West is just a bear with his feet
nailed to a unicycle yeah Kanye's just a
bear with his feet nailed to the Petals
of a unicycle
sadly squealing around Owens doesn't
know better
um they need to be called in and Molina
Abdullah the co-founder of blmla says
she did
someone said someone said isn't Candace
married and has children
yeah yeah and and
you show me you show me a married person
that tells you they never cheated and
I'll show you a [ __ ] liar sir
I don't know if you have to go that hard
I'm sure some guys don't cheat most of
them Jesus you're you really you really
shouldn't have done that much Molly like
you destroyed your like you're you're
some part of your brain amen after
seeing the photo Abdullah tried
contacting Kanye online I released a
statement and black lives matter
Grassroots released a statement all
seeking to call is that what the roots
is doing now
he's still hanging out with Jimmy Fallon
right so now it's just a root it's oh
it's the roots with Rome and even came
back to Owens in and say you know we can
help educate you if you don't know now
you know yes
[Laughter]
set it up lady
I want to familiarize you with the
history of this country of why we say
black lives matter black lives matter is
really a rallying cry to end up violence
against people okay
Kanye took to Instagram to respond to
the backlash saying black lives matter
was a scam
it was what a troll bro
you know why it can't be you right troll
boy
uh
uh everyone knows that black lives
matter was a scam now it's over you're
welcome
I mean I don't remember saying thank you
Kanye said look now I know you all know
think I'm a hero okay and I accept that
forecasted the end of black lives matter
I will say that we aren't going anywhere
no one talks about you anymore I mean
let's be honest nobody talks about
anymore so what that means one or two
things is you guys are going away or
there's going to be another horrible
incident where black lives matter gets
re-energized right before the midterm
elections Dom Florida no it's not here
not here not here boy we are allowed to
run you remember when they tried
remember when they tried for five
minutes and we shut that [ __ ] down so
quick like no that's not happening they
burned down like one store in Tampa and
we're like that's it we're done now
regardless of how many t-shirts he puts
on are prints or distributes no one has
sold more t-shirts more black people
than black lives matter
so go [ __ ] yourself all right you guys
just a t-shirt company yeah I mean
seriously but is it black lives
I wasn't I wasn't I don't I don't know I
was gonna say you should tweet that
that's very funny regardless of how many
statements twist that knife a little bit
that's why I don't want to say it well
it's good you should tweet that's why I
pulled back and didn't say it the
founder Harvey Levin weighed in about
Kanye's response oh good I was worried
that the [ __ ] talk about PT Barnum
that this [ __ ] guy the the guy by the
way who started out as a people's court
reporter is now gonna tell me what he
thinks thank God that when there's
something going on with black people we
have this Jewish guy to ask about it for
two things with BLM one is the
organization and the second is the
movement the problem is Kanye didn't
distinguish between the two and it was
unclear what exactly he was talking
about both both
both of
about the criticism
is that where Quest love is that you
were talking about earlier big Marilyn
Manson fan I see
hey isn't that the kid who stole his
grandma's car and smoking with
cigarettes I think they're doing hood
rat stuff
doing hood of that [ __ ] he's like a
[ __ ] extra from don't be a menace to
society While Drinking Your Juice in the
Hood is that one of The Blind Side is it
the Blind Side kid isn't that the fat
kid who smokes crack from Stand By Me or
lean on me
that weird fat mulatto girl from Cobra
Kai got a tan yes
[ __ ] Nemesis in his third form at the
end of the [ __ ] Resident Evil 3. hey
give her a break she was just kicked out
of the junkyard gang
Jesus Christ
okay we're done
against Kanye
hey you leave Sexual Chocolate alone
oh
leave Coco be scared alone
[ __ ] golf
but echoed by contributing Vogue editor
Gabriella karifa Johnson
'll pump the brakes [ __ ] slam on them
like in a movie before you crash into
somebody
I want to leave I want to leave Back to
the Future [ __ ] marks all along the
road from how hard I jam on those breaks
Vogue
wait
Royce correct me if I'm wrong
that's the fashion magazine right like
vote like vogue vogue vogue right no way
so like the one that used to have
beautiful supermodels on it all the time
oh no
the one that the one that even the women
who worked for the magazine while they
didn't stack anywhere near up to the
models were all still hot and we're
fashionable clothes look I'm just hoping
maybe Vogue is a deep dish pizza place
that'll make much more sense maybe they
mean Vogue pizza in Chicago
whoa is that anything like a feather and
fin oh [ __ ]
the criticism against Kanye's apparel
was echoed by contributing Vogue editor
Gabriella karifa Johnson Gabriella
harifa Johnson you're like three
ethnicities
who called the shirt dangerous nickname
cheese Whiz Khalifa by the way called
the shirt dangerous while she wears her
shirt by a guy who probably molested
women yeah he may have raped and Rachel
Wood the Army is not lost on me that
they used to shirts he's wearing they
used to say the same thing about Marilyn
Manson what he was doing to kids and
look that was bad it's going to be
dangerous and now she's doing the same
thing to Kanye is hilarious so how is
the shirt dangerous is there asbestos in
it is it made of some sort of nuclear
materials rifa Johnson who called the
shirt dangerous what is it made of job
applications
look do you want it look a shirt can't
be dangerous all right unless it's on
fire or it's being worn by draws and
he's getting power bombed okay
what
poor guy poor guy
oh God he's puking
Kanye first responded by making fun of
her wardrobe
of course [ __ ] I'm not letting people
go to bed thinking I don't mean but
Gabrielle at 5 p.m today for two hours
then went to dinner at 30. uh Anna had
baz learn film our meeting and we are
editing tonight we took pics and I was
instructed not to post them I felt like
she was being used like Trevor Noah and
other black people to speak on my
expression she expressed that her
company did not instruct her to speak on
my t-shirt expression we apologize to
each other for the way we made each
other feel we actually got along and
have both experienced the fight for
Acceptance in Worlds and not ours she
disagreed I just agreed at least we both
whatever but later posted on social
media saying quote no no no no no no no
I want to know how he made fun of her no
that's what I yeah you guys left out the
good point let me know the good Virgie
thank you Gabby is my sister and said he
met with her to reconcile this isn't
Kanye's first Scandal either her
scandal
it's a t-shirt it's a [ __ ] t-shirt
and it's a t-shirt that just said White
lives matter did they like it's again
this thing that bothers you you say you
can't admit that black lives matter is
about black lives mattering it's about
how much we hate white people we're on
the brink of [ __ ] world war three and
this [ __ ] is mad about a shirt
though some of his past songs talked
about racism he's come under Fire that's
why they killed that French Duke French
Ferdinand you know that because he had a
bad shirt they didn't like oh man killed
him
for other statements in recent years
like in 2018
was wearing an I eat ass shirt yeah they
were like bro come on man slavery wasn't
real in an interview and at this point
Kanye appears to be standing by his
shirt despite the pushback from fellow
celebrities and everyday people
good good good some people need to
people need to do this
and photos online from his fashion show
also show she looks like she
wanted to be Indian but she's black
instead
other people including some of his
models wearing the same shirts on the
Run he's not the vice president we know
Connie's had some challenges with mental
health issues oh let's do that says the
guy who interviewed who went and flew to
DC to interview and suck Gavin newsom's
dick so shut up we aren't allowed to
shame people for having any sort of
mental problems right unless it's Kanye
West and he's not if we disagree with
him then we can sort of just slip that
in there to discredit I'm like well you
know he's everybody who everybody who
would wear a white lives matter shirt is
mentally ill is what he's explaining to
us right now dude it wasn't even that
bad it was [ __ ] stupid anyways
there's a [ __ ] the Lincoln Show links
goes to [ __ ] a screenshot of the two
posts it's the only place I could find
it so it's not even worth it it's not
even worth it dude he just basically
said How is this [ __ ] going to talk
about fashion okay that's fair it's
pretty funny yeah it's the same same
reaction we had Are you standing by this
too yeah she appears to be standing by
it I checked her Instagram and she
reposted it of course Candace Owens
isn't gonna back down this is money
making for her yeah it's appearing to
also say that she agrees with the
statement that they made it that fashion
show well it certainly Sparks a lot of
conversation yes definitely oh there you
go these certainly does Sparkle this is
quiet you remember thank you ma'am
remember you said Brad Garrett no
actually no actually she she's the one
that sounds like super Dave